[Applause]
it's like why are we elongating the most
annoying song the thing we get the most
negative feedback about
on the song people don't love it but
some people don't take it off well
because
i like it tradition
you don't listen to the podcast
emily listens to the podcast 60 times a
week actually yes more than anyone
that's into any podcast ever
is it still going as long no no it's a
it's a short little the opening song
could
yeah why don't we just start
okay i'll add that to my list if that's
annoying sorry because i'll call the
composer when i listen to other podcasts
i get annoyed by their opening song too
i'm like i get it like i've heard it
like i got it i like to sound cute
i'm like why are you punishing the true
fans with this long ass because then if
we didn't have it if we didn't have that
people back we don't know when it's
starting we didn't get a sound cue well
that's someone that has down syndrome
well that's our main fan base
buddies is our sponsoring organization
what else what are the other problems
people are having with the podcast oh my
god the same stuff we've had the whole
time what i'm shrill
interrupting is the big it's like i need
to stop i'm really i went on prozac are
we up my prozac um i'm getting am i
getting better at it or no it's getting
better it fluctuates you know but i
heard when i was younger that was like
now you can interrupt and we can
interact with your voice yeah by the way
now i know how annoying it is because
i was just
i was just interrupted by whitney
cummings and it is brutal it's something
else but god forbid you put that near
the microphone so people hear it okay
y'all well any other feedback you have
please send it to emily directly she
loves feedback via diana
i take feedback really well
it's one of my best qualities
[Laughter]
oh my god
i love like when women just silence
themselves just doing it so the guys
don't have to do it for you they're just
like i'll handle it so okay real quick
um you know what was weird when that
just happened i kind of cut myself off
and i know that probably sounded like an
edit
we have those sometimes yeah we have
sometimes i have to edit around an
actual moment because it sounds like an
edit
that's the craziest problem makes anyone
feel better i also interrupt myself yeah
that's true and we change lanes real
fast
yeah i just don't i don't it is the kind
of thing where it's weird because i
think sometimes i'm trying to save emily
editing time don't worry about that
okay i never complained about it uh
ever i'm a real chill and then i also um
uh don't want the podcast to be
unnecessarily long you know so i don't
know it's just like i i think there's a
couple other neuroses that are making it
besides just my natural like add
tourettes and whatever autism asperger's
or whatever um and uh i just like i
don't want the podcast to be long so a
lot of it is just pressure that i'm
putting on myself and also trying to
make sure the conversation stays
interesting right but i have been
listening to podcasts and when people
interrupt it annoys me but here's
another thing we've talked about this
since the
start since i came on it's like you're a
consummate performer and you're a
perfectionist so i think that this
format is tricky because you're in your
head about things that are podcast
format like nature of the beast but for
your brain it's like oh that's but
that's that's what a podcast is you know
what i mean it's just in my brain i
think as a lass
and as a comedian to be like you nothing
can ever be boring
oh yeah and but that's impossible in a
yeah but i think that part of podcast
this is a hot take but
some of the podcasts that i enjoy
listening to are kind of boring yeah
like it's i'm not because they're having
a conversation with you do you know what
i mean totally
the best version of a conversation that
you don't have to participate in or
impress anyone you get to just like hear
people talking right but it's so nice
you're doing laundry yeah you know like
you're doing other things while you're
listening and if something is too like
yeah yeah yeah it's actually a little
bit stressful because you're like oh
wait i need to write that down or wait i
need to yeah i miss that because people
know comedians with podcasts like they
know their their performance brain but
they do like this more casual side of
them which is like oh this isn't whitney
performing this is whitney like riffing
and this is when he naturally like
naturally do you know me
miss casual yeah that's just super cash
so um the podcast is
in an evolution
it's in a chrysalis i've decided
that if there's not a guest available uh
it's the summer everybody's gone
everybody they're in italy everybody's
in italy no everybody's now in london
they've moved on from italy and they're
now in london here's the thing you guys
like for if you care about stuff like
this hollywood maybe um
uh
the the entertainment business used to
be
um
a business a business
it used to be an actual functioning
business and a couple things happened
number one
really talented people stopped uh
begging
[Music]
idiots that are in charge to like them
and they're like oh we're just gonna
start our own thing so there was like a
mass exodus into podcasting into youtube
into whatever like if a 21 year old
wants to be an actress two auditions
doesn't get it she's like fuck this i'm
a youtube star yeah oh she's on tick
tock i'm not doing it right i'm not
gonna go grovel in front of 15
middle-aged men and be like do you want
to fuck me and do the women think i'm
funny but do you want to fuck like it's
impossible i'm not going to schedule my
three different day jobs around one
15-minute audition at like cowenga in
hollywood like they already gave
hollywood baby baby
yeah that's going to
yeah even away fourth daughter's cousin
did you want me to finish that sentence
yeah i mean i could have i teach see how
frazzled i'm learning i could have just
finished the taking that off the plate
it's a codependent thing i want to be
able to finish people's sentences i'm
like no i got this yeah yeah yeah so
we're going to do some episodes where
we're just checking in we're talking
about current events some hot topics
we're going to talk about some pet
peeves and as i'm working on new
stand-up i'm going to run it by you guys
before it's done which i feel like will
be a kind of a cool process for you guys
to like see how it works without the
sausages different generations yeah of
comedians you guys they'll have some too
and we'll like work on jokes i love that
i just you know what i'm saying that's
very exciting because when i do the
interviews i know you it might not seem
like it because i'm basically only
talking about ancestral trauma but i
watch
all their movies listen to their pockets
oh you do a lot of prep yeah well i want
to make so sure that i'm not asking a
podcast guest a question that a billion
other people ask them right and then i'm
just boring the shit out of everybody
including the guests and myself so i
just i i also the amount of research i
have to do for all of them
i would rather be putting into writing
jokes yeah because i'm gonna have to be
in cincinnati on september 8th with a
new hour of materials
so you guys i just want you to know that
my netflix special is called jokes it is
out now um thank you guys for watching
and being so lovely it's a suspiciously
positive feedback so far i was waiting
for that other shoe to drop it kind of
dropped the other day on twitter but uh
uh initially it was going to air late
september and netflix for whatever
reason was like they said push the gas
push
that turn around was it was crazy
in may it aired in january and because
no july you know what i do with january
and july what my mom did for me and my
sister's names like if anyone has more
than one kid yeah my name was
whitney
you know what i mean
yeah yeah like it was never just whitney
it was always the other name first so
that's what happens um but yeah so
anyway so it came out in two months so
now i have to basically have an entire
new hour of material uh two months later
which is
a month and a half later which is kind
of unheard of but i'm going to do it so
september 8th i will be in cincinnati
ohio i'll be at the taft theater this is
a rescheduled show so your tickets will
work september 9th i'll be in
philadelphia pennsylvania at the miller
theater i am so excited to go back to
philadelphia all my exes and all the
weirdo older men that grew to me when i
was in college come through so it worked
yeah
i want to see you look how rude she is
no they're all dead
i am also going to be in charlottesville
september 24th at the paramount theater
charlottesville virginia that is and
then i'm starting another tour to work
on my next hour um because she just
never wants to see us yeah i do whatever
i can to just make sure i'm gone as much
as possible yeah and um because uh when
you're working on new material as a
comedian you want to go to clubs and i
get to do more shows in the city so it's
like if you're not able to come one
night i'm going to be there for like a
couple nights october 21st through 23rd
i'm in san jose california san jose san
jose improv
it's an incredible venue september uh uh
17th through 19th i'm in sacramento
california november
what did i say i heard september
huh
a lot of s is not a lot of s's in that
line oh my god these young people
they're such haters it's unbelievable
it's true
november i came out a hater dude
whitneycummings.com why do i have to
announce this on here it's because it's
exciting it's a new club yeah okay
because you club them you're right i
club you guys it is called the i club
you tour cause i club you
uh uh november 25th and 26th isn't that
thanksgiving how sad is mine no it's not
yeah i mean it is thanksgiving but it's
not sad okay
but it's in phoenix arizona i mean that
is good
i'm kidding we love you phoenix
i'm going to be at stand up live
december 9-11 i'll be in oxnard
california if you're like la area it's
only like an hour february 10th through
14th i'll be in irvine california at the
irvine improv those shows always go
terribly so i cannot wait happy
valentine's day you know why because the
irvine going back to clubs is always
kind of wild you know but um you're i'm
like it's just once you get to a certain
level and then you go back and you're
like why am i watching people deep
throat salmon wait that's kind of fun
maybe it'll come yeah yeah that's is
that what it takes to get you to go
take the nike outlet for someone who's
never
um okay so i also have just a couple
really quick updates and then we're
gonna talk army hammer we're gonna talk
britney spears we're gonna get sued
let's go oh no first when i tell you
something big news
we have a live show another live show
live show
it is my birthday live show so my
birthday is september 4th so if you care
about me at all
you will show up live to my live show
this is how we're gonna celebrate my
birthday come celebrate with us uh and
um don't be like my parents show up for
my birthday 6 p.m pacific standard time
tickets on sale today
live show whitney's bat bat bap day
we're gonna do funny videos from fans
we're gonna
bet no we're doing happy ba
day cute uh we're gonna do dares you
guys are gonna we're gonna have a lot of
fan engagement we're gonna take advice
give advice take questions
last time i gave advice to people that i
want for my birthday is to give advice
yeah
uh last time we did a live show we all
got piercings and i ate
500 edibles that didn't kick in oh my
god oh my god next morning yeah
please tune in
learning unless you're my parents and
then the live show is um october 32nd
okay so we'll see you there wait also
for the live show send us videos of you
wishing whitney a happy birthday do
something crazy say something funny do
something inventive and original um and
we're gonna throw you on the screen and
don't watch this happy birthday i love
you and change my life right like to be
entertained jump off a building
send those to the good good for you fans
at gmail.com um you can also submit
stuff to our instagram page we're going
to start doing a lot more um original
original content on the good for you
page i'm going to start a series today
actually called um celebs they're worse
than us and then just show you things
around whitney's house so um
that's good for you podcast yeah that's
funny as shit all right let's get sued
oh great oh there's a couple things i
want to talk about uh some jokes that
i'm working on we'll do that in a second
some pet peeves that i have yeah um
i've got grievances right we're gonna be
ranting and coming
um for ya but first let's talk about
some news stories because i've got
thoughts we've all got thoughts army
hammer
there is a army hammer a hammer family
documentary coming out right house of
hammers yes
i think september 2nd on discovery plus
yeah i work for them i'm just gonna say
that was weird
and so i just i guess a bunch of texts
were released but
the main thing is that this is a fam a
generational family thing this is
like rife so with
your favorite thing
ancestral trauma so part of the reason i
want to bring this up has to do with the
fact that now you guys know why i am
always banging the drum about ancestral
trauma absolutely so in a way i'm i'm
not exonerating the behavior i don't
know the extent of all of it i'm sure
there should i don't know and i'm not
going to be caught up on but um but in
terms of all this like i will there be a
cuz i guess his parents and grandparents
generations so his great great mother
killed a woman giving her an abortion uh
and then went back to russia was the
abortion something she i don't know if
she was a russian diplomat's wife but he
wasn't a russian diplomat so how was he
giving her the abortion he
i don't i don't just know why her hand
is adding up to him she's punching her
down the stairs calling yeah with a
hammer he's with a hammer
that's where the name comes from the
grandfather murdered a man in his own
home like in the grandfather's home for
a gambling debt and because he thought
he was hitting on his wife who's didn't
right but i mean that's the best place
to murder someone yeah oh no i know
there are there were soviet connections
oh his grandfather gave money to cover
up watergate they think he paid money to
cover up watergate okay um but a couple
plus things he did he convinced china to
lend la two giant pandas
for the olympics in 1984. that is animal
abuse well i love panda that is honestly
the worst thing you have said so far no
okay oh can i tell you something you're
really going to hate he sold
knock off fake fabric eggs
that's a crime well in that case i'm
supporting him oh my god yeah
i mean actually that is
thank you there is no disgusting
behavior i cannot defend you know that
is my you know that is
your kink i was i believe i was put on
this earth to be a criminal defense
attorney i'm serious and i still might
all right i'm still but let me just
focus on why this is so important which
is that ancestral trauma is very real
and i would like to get to a point in
society where we are able to sue our
parents and grandparents
for the dna and the epigenetics they
have given to us because it is i love
that that is it i mean obviously
whatever because also one of my biggest
pet peeves is people who in their 40s
won't stop blaming their parents for
their
their own behavior but i i do think it's
like we should at like
15 get a sit down that's like hey
this is where you come from this is this
train has left the track yeah this is
what it's what is it uh d uh dna loads
the gun environment pulls the trigger so
we know what your gun is loaded with we
know where this is going it's not good
so sorry yeah
good luck but here's your
lobotomy and pros out yeah yeah yeah
whatever and you don't get to watch
pornhub yeah and you never had to buy
ropes or right yeah yeah
yeah
like the way that the genetic trait of
like toxic masculinity that has come
down through
this family tree the only thing left to
do was for army to be a cannibal
in terms of like that's all there was
they ran out of team miranda they
murdered they cheat they they're they
thieve they embezzled they did
government stuff yeah like there's
nothing i will say but here's what i
will say
as someone that loves to generalize like
for a living i don't think he's a
cannibal i don't think he is i kind of
don't think so either let's say he is a
cannibal let's say he is eating women
he's eating the wrong ones obviously
he's got some kind of imbalance so if
you just start eating older women
that have a prescription for wellbutrin
for prozac
you know what i'm saying yeah life will
get better just eat women who have
antidepressants in their bloodstream
your whole shift your vitamins
yeah exactly yeah
like adderall so you focus on something
else right right right yeah i don't know
it just
it's
again i think that all of this boils
down to
you cannot date girls that are 20 and
think you're gonna get away with
anything right yeah because also to me
it's like some 21 year olds in your
house and you're gonna tie them up like
how do you think that's gonna end first
of all why are you even tying up 21 year
olds like they're not the best way to
keep a 21 year old in your bedroom is to
just draw a set of angel wings on the
wall
just paint some angel wings and you'll
have a line of them
you have a line of 20 year olds around
the block bring a ring light if you'd
like really
just set that puppy up there's easier
ways to keep 20 year olds in your
bedroom you are rich you're gorgeous yep
and you're famous yeah you know what's
leaving right right right right
that's a triple threat yeah that's what
i'm saying like when then when the
people are like we couldn't leave and
it's like what was keeping you there
like his beautiful eyes yeah
just walk away
his gravelly voice yeah
like we couldn't leave why why not what
was stopping you i mean too hot have you
seen him without a shirt yeah like
that's your choice babe that is okay but
that is like one thing when you if you
because you can hear some of the voice
notes that he sent to these girls
but also like
i don't know i think that if there was
not a crime involved it's
not cool to release stuff like that i
think it's like that's fair i think that
it's unnecessary and it's unfair and i
think that when you're you know young
and you've been hurt or cheated on or
had something with a guy you thought was
special and that it wasn't
if i was that age i would have done the
same thing i would have like gone
nuclear yeah
i think these girls will look back and
go i am so bummed right that when you
google me and every employer googles me
that is the number one search but there
was
some accusations of crime that are much
darker i'll stay out of that but here's
my thing about the text number one
here's where some of the texts okay i
decide when you eat when you sleep great
i want to be a baby i'd love that
you wouldn't want to get a text from
someone that hot saying i want to eat
you
but also here's the thing
he's not a cannibal every girl that he
dated was 90 pounds fucking wet there's
nothing to eat right if he was really a
cannibal he would not be dating are you
20 year old models he would have been
dating ashley graham are you
are you considered a cannibal if you
never act on the impulse like he could
be a cannibal he could desire to yes
i'm a pedophile just fyi right but i've
never acted on it i think if you're
actually one you don't text about it
okay
i think it was just it's something we're
all latching on to because it's like
crazy it's had it's interest it's
headlining it's yeah it's good
i mean he did do like masochistic stuff
like he did carve the letter a
a sharpie heart on my boob earlier and
not that i ever get naked in front of my
employees that'd be super unprofessional
um but i had a heart on my boob that was
like clearly sharpie but emily was
across the room she's like did you get a
tattoo like do you think i would get
attention
don't no
like maybe i mean and not on a live show
that's true that's okay it's true
yeah the fact that we didn't see you
getting that tattoo should have been a
tip-off that it wasn't a real title
it wasn't content i should have known it
was not permanent
uh yeah all right so he's not a cannibal
there is no proof of his cannibalism if
he was a cannibal and there weren't any
other allegations i could probably get
past it yeah i just would never take him
to like korean bbq do you know what i
mean don't let him around my dog i
wouldn't let him around the whole i
would never let him donate plasma coming
with a boner you know what i mean oh my
god
i just um
i don't know i just think in general
like the tying up thing is it's like he
was practicing the hobby of special
japanese knots like that is like and his
wife elizabeth chambers like tried to
like be like good a hobby like great but
like it just happened to be like
something he used in his sex
capabilities okay but there's something
hot about a man that knows how to tie a
rope when a guy has a boat and he ties
it yeah i'm canonically hot i'm a
squirrel if there is not when you see a
guy who can really put a halter away and
show it properly so that all you have to
do is pull the string out at the end
like that is very hot to me but like
i'm just let's get granular on this sex
thing because the ropes are i i'm just
trying to understand what's hot about it
because if you tie me up fully i'm tied
up my arm okay let's say my arms are
tied up my feet are tied up is someone
who is not 21 i am thrilled with this
arrangement i would love to just lay
there and do absolutely nothing and have
no like
no i have an excuse
but as the guy if you're doing that to a
girl and you have duct tape over her
mouth she can't suck your dick she can't
play with your balls she can't jerk you
off she can't put her finger in your
butthole she can't
put her finger in her own butthole i
don't know where we are
anymore um we don't know what kids are
doing there's nothing she's a fleshlight
i mean there's nothing to do
yeah
do you know how many quadriplegics would
love to fuck army hammer
just find one
but also like it's actually good what
like when i look at some of these guys
these days and i've been i've dated some
guys like this that are just like and
then we're gonna do this then i'm gonna
tie you up and then i'm gonna do this
and it's like is at any point are you
just gonna are you gonna fuck me right
right am i gonna get fucked like i am
down to fuck you and everything you want
to do none of it involves fucking you
don't need props
you don't have to go to joann's fabrics
oh my god
he's like i have a coupon i want to use
it i get it you went to michael's like
how
when did men decide they wanted to
become the carrot top of fucking like
just the amount of props involved like
remember the good old days when you
would just fuck
that you don't need a prop message i'm
gonna say when did vaginas get so boring
yeah that it was like ah vaginas
buttholes are on the table now yeah we
have three
warm holes none of them are good enough
and you can break my tents now
like you have four options that's still
not enough nuts
it is nice
that's ungrateful this is also a man
that can have as many threesomes as you
want yeah
also his wife is stunning he has a wow
gorgeous wife yeah for every model
there's a guy who's sick of fucking her
that is a quote that is a quote that i
heard when i was around your age who's
the hottest girl in the room the one you
haven't fucked yet
have you ever heard that grace
i forgot how rough it was when i heard
that for the first time
because guys will i mean
i have the privilege of being friends
with a bunch of scumbags well also look
at that look at fucking jay-z yeah no
you're right oh cheating yeah dude that
was that's insider that's yeah that's
sure he cheated or like cecil
i mean they also think emil
emily ratted
oh yeah
it's about variety it's about your new
vagina and yes and if you're a
narcissist right that's just the deal
there's just like
i just don't unders for me
the whole the and maybe this is a girl
guy thing but like sex gets better the
more you do it with the same yes
yes it does it's uncomfortable yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying so it's just i
also find like the spontaneity of sex
like i wouldn't want someone to be like
hold that thought and then like pull out
a trunk of like ropes and
no are you just practicing for your
magic yeah yeah exactly like is this
he's like david flipping through a book
of knots
i haven't tried this one yet but like it
gets give me a minute i've lost the urge
it's gonna take me probably like a
couple tries but also like okay let's
just get
my favorite granular um
if you're tying me up like
either i'm really tied up
right for realsies right and then when
you're done doing whatever you're
doing yeah i then
you have to untie me right right which
is like it's just so it it makes it all
less hot no it's correct because the
wrap-up i have anadonia which is what
annie hall was originally called the
woody allen movie which is it's very
hard to enjoy the present because you're
so busy mourning the present being over
yeah we're stressing out about what's
about to happen that's us on vacation
[Laughter]
the whole time we're on vacation we're
like this is so great we should come
here on vacation
all the time and then we're the right
way yeah to just
relax come here
we were there um but uh so all i'm doing
is like who's gonna unravel the rope
right right or you don't really do it
and then i'm pretending oh and then
that's what that's i've done that work
with guys where they'll like put you in
handcuffs or something but they're not
real and you're just like that's act
that's free acting class but
you should be saying thank you
you were just saved i don't know how
much insert price of acting
pretending to be tied up is
like one giant kegel for your body it
also takes it's so much work
who am i i'm never i've never had
anything introduced in the bedroom like
that am i just a loser no
like no
say it now
based on the way you just confronted me
about that i can only imagine what you
would do if somebody even tried to
introduce a prop in the bedroom
exactly show me that is literally bring
it out you don't see it because you're
the dom yeah
yeah you have to do it
say it
say you love my pussy
say it
that's a really good impression
that's not your impression you are a dom
you're just editing me while he eats
your puzzle oh my god oh my god she has
one of those like laptop tables from l.l
bean teen
he's like please for the love of god
turn off whitney's voice
or actually he might like it better he's
eating my pussy hollywood baby
baby
okay just checking thank you needed to
get a reason i've never had a guy try to
do something dominant choke you you're
blonde see blondes they don't do that
too nothing i've never had anyone do
anything it's a blonde thing i couldn't
tell you when the last time somebody
didn't try to choke me what
give me the logistics are you on top
was it after you were ordering at a
restaurant
yes yep no every time i go out to eat
every time
god we but here's my question in what
position like when does it is it
introduced like
do they want you i don't get it it just
it
it doesn't matter wait the the choking
the joking it doesn't matter like what
what happened when you tried to
girl boss
oh yes
yes yes
this is literally the most psycho shit
is it uh yes grace tried to equal out
the page i will maybe
i just feel like maybe you have to stop
listening to beyonce or i don't know
something needs a habit where no it's my
friends it's my question quality i
understand in a lot of ways but this is
where it's just drawing the line yes uh
i'm a feminist um
and
are we but we're the good kind
the kind that knows their place yes
well i've been talking a lot to my
friends about how like guys will just do
stuff to us in bed without really like
asking and it's usually pretty like
innocuous but we want them to ask like
kind of guys can i touch your face hey
crazy no that is not like that secret if
you're worried there is a vacuum that
you've ever watered
if you did
um but like
i don't know we were like what would
happen if we like tried so i was if you
okay i i was hooking up with this guy
for the first time and we were both for
the first time i think you were also
standing up we were so drunk no we were
not standing up okay um we were so drunk
i was on top of him and i was like what
would happen if i just like tried to
choke him a little bit
by the way this is how women get
murdered yeah that's true i know two
hands is also like at a house i'd never
been bitch the only thing that's in
someone else's home yeah this is
literally someone that has
you were probably disrespect yeah i was
like i i'm claiming my space the only
person that they can wait he told me to
do this is ronda rousey is the only
person that can do it so wait did you
use two hands or no one hand and it
wasn't even i didn't i was just like a
light
a gentleman what did he do he just gave
me a look like
like i've never seen somebody look so
like confused and like taken aback at
the same time and i was like i'm so
sorry
are you telling me that your friend your
roommates and friends tell you you
should do this right no do we no we just
like talk about it well my friend one of
my friends um she a guy slapped her in
bed without like like it wasn't on the
table on the face
not like a spanking he slapped her
across the face so she was like
she was like no no if you like him it's
hot
if
stop pretending you don't know the
difference if it's if you have a no i'm
full i'm fully on board with that and
aware of that and i agree with that yeah
but this was like
she was just like
i was so surprised that he did that like
it didn't hurt and it wasn't like i
wasn't whatever but that's part of it
she was so surprised that he did that so
she was just like i just slapped him
back i didn't know what to do okay
and he was like you slapped me and she
was like you slapped me first oh my god
women are broken we got broken when did
this happen who what who did did oprah
do this who did this right oh my god who
did this anyone slapped me that i gave
the privilege
of fucking me imagine
i would call the police
immediately followed by their mother um
so yeah so this whole thing i just
really feel like this is
the army hammer thing is important
because it is
i think on some level this should i'm
not saying exonerate him i'm not
whatever i don't even know all the
allegations i'm just saying this is a
great opportunity for us to all look
into our ancestry
with love and forgiveness and patience
they did the best they came with the
tools they have and they go and go like
what did i inherit like what is what
what am i just um
sort of going through life as a zombie
doing because programmed for it i'm
programmed for it like i i got this
honestly i like to say like what did you
get honestly what did you just inherit
that you did not ask for that now you
have to undo like whatever that is
unlearn i have it with addiction i have
it with ocd i have it with perfection i
know none of that is my choice none of
that is
from a trauma in my life because i think
we all spend so much time going like oh
this childhood trauma is why i do this
it's like bitch this was probably like
eight years ago you know i mean all of
our rational fears of the heights of
this of that like it probably just meant
like one of your ancestors fell off a
fucking cliff right so you're a clumsy
you're clumsy so you should look at that
you should look at that maybe you could
take a deep dive do pilates i don't know
oh my god
don't wear heels like you can fix this
um so yeah so army you getting choked i
don't know what to do about that
i i maybe it's because i'm like slightly
older i don't want to be equals in the
bedroom
i don't either yeah i don't want it i
don't either but i also i want to be a
victim of violence
but here's the thing i will say if you
are like slapped and there's no
like you first should have like
yeah like a little test you got to build
up to things yeah yeah but also there is
if you're really into the person
and it happens and it's like
funny and yeah he knew what he was doing
there's something great about it yeah
was your choke the first hook up
like the first time you hooked up with
that guy was this the first time you
hooked up with him was a choke perhaps
he's not listening i know he's not
listening
for 11 hours at this point
it was like four in the morning i've
been working
since
okay okay eleven hours it was a very
long date okay that was your you were a
cat i would have choked myself
okay well that's
another thing
um imagine spending 11 hours with a girl
and then she chokes you you're like yes
um but yeah i don't that's that okay
let's move on there's a lot to do
there's a lot to do and i'm trying to
make this guys
these episodes can't be three hours
anymore we're not in the pajama party
pandemic anymore okay um but uh what is
the next thing oh the britney stuff
britney spears britney spears okay so
for just for context kevin federline
released kevin fetterline and his
children released a couple of videos
from their children kevin fetterline and
he okay yes there are kevin and britney
she carried them they're barely his
correct correct they're
right so they can't even dance now they
are 15 and 16.
they took some videos four years ago of
brittany in the car we can play one
maybe right now yeah we still have them
we'll play it i'm sure you've heard it
come in here when we're trying to go to
bed and then you just
go
house if and
forget something that i know this is my
house
if i want to come in here and give you
lotion for your face cause it is coarse
and all you tell me no it's fine it's
fine no it's not fine
you all better start respecting me are
we clear
yeah and when robin calls and you're all
you're all even robin's a fucking kid
she goes what have you been doing to
your kids you're all you all need to
start treating me like a woman with
worth
i am a woman
okay
be nice to me do you understand
yeah
you've lost your mind
have you lost your fucking mind
i do care but i'm shocked as fuck with
you and i don't know what to do and i'm
scared of you because you're weird
because you're going through puberty i
don't know what to say but i do care
more than you know
but don't be my little body can't handle
all of that it's like sometimes i just
don't even know what to say with you
i was in shock and i do care no you know
if you really cared you wouldn't take my
phone away for
literally i was in shock in the store
when i looked down and jaden how are you
so cool about that your brother being
with bear is big feet size 13 now well
he's my brother
and all the more exposed his feet your
blood and ice cream shop in in in alaska
weather
don't you think that's a little odd no
oh yeah i think your phone should be
gone uh okay for a very long time uh
yeah for not wearing shoes yeah
yeah yeah my phone's just to be taken
away forever because you know what jaden
mom decides to take it away for me not
wearing sheets
that's hilarious
didn't obviously think
attention baby is that why you're saying
well apparently i wanted to do that in
the first place but you keep
interrupting every sentence i say so
what i seem like in my mind i think you
just care about yourself because you
won't let us speak one word and you
won't let us go anywhere we want to know
i want to hear what you have to say i'm
listening well i forget honestly best
parenting i've witnessed in years yeah i
like the honesty i like her being like
i'm scared of you because you're weird
you're weird what's scarier and weirder
than a thirteen-year-old
absolutely nothing nothing nothing
teenage boys yeah groceries scary yes
socks yeah and then for brittany to say
think someone else is weird yeah that's
a weird impressive you know what i'm
saying so it's i love the way that she's
wearing i mean look this might be like a
southern thing i mean i
the fact that she wasn't slapping him
yeah upside the head yeah i used to say
like grabbing his ear i used to if i
acted out in public i would get a pinch
yeah like my arm would get pinched the
back of my neck would get pinched my ear
would get pinched or i'd be smacked
upside the head if i didn't say yes
ma'am or yes sir oh if i talked back to
my mom like that i would have gotten
soap in my mouth i i talked back i did
get something yeah i spent a lot of my
life as a child wondering what the
difference between replying and talking
back was so emily i didn't understand i
was like am i not allowed to talk and
then i get more soap but i'm not clear
if it's any time i talk talking back
more so it was like unbelievable so so
let's do i'm your mom um uh
go to your room and don't talk back no i
i i can't go to my room right now i have
to i have to feed the cat why are you
talking back because i'm just not
talking back i'm answering a question
well you don't need to feed cats just
open the door and let it out okay
but you the last time that you said this
then then i got in trouble for letting
the cat out you're a nightmare we never
should have adopted you oh my god
but that is fun that is funny the idea
of what's the difference between talking
back and replying yeah when i wasn't in
hot like when i wasn't in hot water with
them like when i was just like having a
normal conversation i'd be like so is
this talking back and then i get in
trouble even when i wasn't that's i used
to do that all the time i just wanted
clarification yeah yeah yeah yeah
because i'll say that to my niece i'm
like my niece like i'm talking back i'm
like how do you know when it's talking
back she's like i just know and i was
like okay you just know yeah it's a vibe
it's an absolutely you did know yeah
we're just trying to make a point which
i actually think it's a it's important
for kids to test their parents yeah like
that's how you learn and parents don't
get to decide like i remember when i
would get in fights with my mom or
something i would just be like you had
me yeah now you have to ask me yeah i
don't know what to tell you i do that
now i didn't ask you you raised me this
is how i am yeah no i don't that is a no
that is a hard no if you spent less time
talking about me in therapy and more
time talking about your actual mom you
might not be in this gym
because i well we're going to get to pet
peeves in a second but i am a little bit
at capacity with people and maybe it's
because they're just getting into
therapy or they're just like discovering
tools or whatever when someone in their
like 30s and 40s is like still blaming
their parents for the daily choices they
make
there's enough access out there to other
information like because it's a little
convenient why does army hammer get to
do it
well
this fucking bitch
it's not talking it's a good point it's
a good point it's a good that is a good
point parents should have to pay for all
medical things too because
[Laughter]
oh i was talking about my eye bags
because i think that that should extend
to cosmetic as well because i was on
facetime with my parents and i was like
like this weak chin off the grass hold
on i was complaining about how my eye
bags looked and my dad was like hey
those are from you your ukrainian
ancestors like you should be proud of
you guys it was like
since when are we like
gung-ho about the fact that
our family came from ukraine you
marching for the ukraine like against
russia being like they should be free
but the imac thing will deal with yeah
but
that okay so here's what i would say
about that which is that anything that
you inherited and sexual trauma or any
kind of genetics that is all
genetics that
you evolved to have to be the most
auspicious for your surroundings yeah
exactly like the potato famine like like
women tended to be like plumper after
that in ireland because they were like
literally storing fat in case there was
a famine again right explains it so like
anything physically that you have that
you're not happy with those attributes
at one time really benefited you when
you lived in the wild you evolved to
have those how would bad eyesight have
the help thought what how would anyone
ever the men were so ugly
the guys in your tribe were hey
um so brittany i think that her
parenting is amazing i don't know if
this is a big story or not but i just
feel the need to say like i mean
the way she talked to her kids is the
way that i like hope people talk to
their children after i see them like out
in public or like at the airport i'm
like i hope in the car yeah that mom you
know
yeah because i also think like when you
see someone not disciplining their child
in public it's sort of like that is kind
of like embarrassing them that could
like be traumatic to them i don't know
when is the right time to do it but i
hope when you get in the car you go ape
shit on that kid and also it was coming
from a place so from what i gathered she
was she was
chastising him for taking his shoes off
in public and it's like she's been
through that remember the gas station oh
yeah she's trying to love you i'm
hearing him she's like you'll never live
this down yeah because also it's like
that is actually kind of funny though
because it's like the idea of like why
can't i just like be barefoot in a
public bathroom it's like honey it's a
long story yeah exactly like just tell
me trust me yeah yeah google.com you
really do not want this side by side
trending on gestures also like because
it's feet related at one point in the
video she says like she references the
fact that her son has size 13 feet it's
like of course he leaked the video he
wanted everybody to know those biggest
feet are that's so weird for like a 13
year old size 13 feet it's huge if
that's the worst video they have this
from this whole time of being like under
a guardianship
because by the way also the fact that
kevin federline thought he was dropping
this bomb that was gonna like break the
internet of how toxic she was right it
was just everyone was like oh wait a
second she should have full of custody
and your judgment is so fucking off and
it's an uphill battle for her it's like
you need to respect me no it's my curfew
get out of here you need to respect me
now i gotta go put on one of my tight bb
peasant tops and dance around
the camera you need to respect me now
give me my pills like she can't win
it is hard but like watching her in that
moment go like i'm a woman yeah you need
to respect me it wasn't even i'm not a
girl i am a woman and you need to
respect
me she was working
yeah this is toxic but i love the fact
that she wasn't saying i'm your mother
no that is gangster dude you say like
i'm your mother is kind of like my
relationship to you is not why you
should respect me you should respect me
because i'm a grown woman and you're a
child you should treat all women like
this yeah thank you brittany yes
we yeah that's a great point also kevin
federline do a sit-up
what are you watching like
get back in the dance studio how dare
you look like that like
where do you get off yeah this is why no
one should get a hunk of money yeah yeah
that they didn't earn yeah like you're
also me why is he
why is he i know you'd never take it
why is he so heavy
it's unbelievable
here's what i'll say if you're that
heavy and you don't have a job
right you have no idea you have
resources that's the thing and money
yeah
you're the one that is setting a
horrible example for those two kids
because you obviously don't take care of
yourself you obviously eat like trash
like your ex-wife works out 20 hours
she's in the gym and posting about it
she's setting her gym on fire just to
take a day off yeah yeah she has to go
to yankee candle again
because those candles are burned down
can we say yankee didn't that get
cancelled did it was dixie chicks dixie
dixie
because it references antebellum yeah
i'm just wondering because i knew a lot
of people growing up named dixie
uh like if you're a person who's named a
term that is now problematic are you
grandfathered in yeah that's what
happened with
remember everything their kid atticus
and then
that second uh
to kill him
watchman yeah yeah came out and he was
not so great and now all these kids are
named ashes
they're gonna need therapy oh no so i
can't gosh that's such a bummer i was
gonna name my kid kevin spacey
speaking of kevin spacey a word from our
sponsor betterhelp much more affordable
than in-person therapy look therapy is
crucial but i am the first to say most
therapists are connors
i'm sorry i just i just don't when i
hear people friends of mine who are like
i can't go to therapy or i'm taking a
couple months off because it's 400 a
week and you have to drive two and a
half hours and it's like it's there's no
parking on top of that it's like it's
actually like 44 minutes oh yeah my god
it no if you i am sitting in that room
until it hits 50 i paid for that time
and i intend to use it yes and then
you're scribbling on a thing that i
can't even see right yeah and like i
don't like all the tricks in the waiting
room of like the i don't mean hookers i
mean like there's like a sandbox that
you can like zen garden with and i know
that you're looking at what i did
afterwards and trying to judge me i
don't like any of it i recently just got
a new therapist because my last
therapist was always taking my i didn't
want to talk about me anymore no she
always was saying that i was right and i
was like this bitch has got to be crazy
if she thinks i'm right inside the
self-awareness to know that i need
someone that always disagrees with me so
now i have a new therapist she's great
betterhelp has
entered the space you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours okay
our listeners get 10 percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
whitney that's betterhelp betterhelp.com
whitney
nice okay now what things i talk to my
therapist about pet peeves pet peeves
all the time yeah um uh i want to get
into some pet peeves that are also some
of these are uh ideas that i'm working
on for stand up but right now i just
want to get into
getting some things off my chest
um
okay
so
i feel like i am
having to pretend
too much when i talk to people
who are um
high performing
you know everyone's a high performer oh
yeah so it's like
guys now they're doing the steam and the
sauna and the burpees and which is great
take care of your health obviously but
it's gotten to a point where it's like
remember there used to be
jocks and nerds yeah now the jocks are
nerds the cerebral they're nerdy about
being jocks totally
yes and it's just like
i it's just
go back to vet the venice beach muscle
beach do some pull-ups where we can
dominate or just keep it to yourself
yeah so it's like it's just it's become
um intrusive into other people's lives
so it's just like i don't need my
enterprise rent-a-car guy to be in
ketosis like you stink like i don't want
to be involved in it like intermittent
fasting and now i have to watch you eat
three jalapenos
like you're just like grumpy all the
time yeah like i don't really need my
like tsa pre-check guy to have like
cauliflower ears like what are you
training
on one hand i go oh men are insecure
about their bodies now right great whoa
now you know what it's like yeah this is
how we've all intermittent fasting that
was our thing it's called anorexia we
invented that you take everything from
us i know world's wild because i always
felt like oh my god me being anorexic is
probably gonna make it so my life is
shorter and i'm probably not healthy but
turns out even my eating disorder
silver lining it seems like it was
exactly what is now recommended by david
sinclair she was always eventually right
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen that's so
true you're right dude you called it any
starter i was just intermittent fasting
yeah
but i guess for me it's like it's a
little convenient some of the beliefs so
it's a lot of like oh you know like
you know
i've been studying a lot i've been
listening to my you know my whatever
your thought leader podcast person is
thought leader and you know it turns out
monogamy's not natural so i don't
believe in monogamy i believe it's like
i don't believe in monogamy but you do
believe in aliens
i do believe we're in a simulation
so
which
you know what i'm saying it feels a
little convenient that we're in a
simulation why did you cheat on me i
don't know we're in a simulation yeah if
somebody's playing you like a sim and
these you chose to go to arizona state
yeah yeah yeah you could eat a new
year's degree in nutrition yeah like
like i can't take you seriously as like
a like a
man who's you know doming me and yeah
someone else is playing right yeah what
is that they're not even doing a good
job
grace is choking and that was that it's
such a great way to have no consequences
for your rape yeah like oh you're in a
simulation yeah so i mean i cheated but
it was not me yeah right right right i
was just on a different level but it is
also it's so annoying because
it's like guys refuse to take like the
shortcut anymore like it used to be like
for a minute the dad bod was in and it
was like you don't have to work out all
the time you can have a dad bod and you
can just like be like a little bit
schlubby and that's hot and you can
embrace it whatever but now it's like
you're doing krav maga like for for self
defense but also to get fit like i'd
rather you just buy a gun
like just buy it
[Laughter]
don't use it just buy it just buy it
just keep it in the safe how about hey
krav papa
spend some time with your children
i see grow men that do like spin classes
like three times they have so many
hobbies how do you teach your child how
to ride a bike
right how about ride a bike with your
kids yeah
i'm just like a little bit obsessed with
all the convenient beliefs it's like as
soon as other people besides men start
making money they're like they move the
goal post like bitcoin now like so now
is i just started making regular actual
now it's it's invisible now it's yeah
money's invisible you can't see it yeah
yeah and i in ten years it won't
everything that you earned won't matter
right right like nothing you're doing
it's just
we're decentralizing current like what
right right
i don't know i just um
also
yeah you don't have to tell everyone
about it like that's the other thing
like you know but it's funny to me
because i do have a couple friends that
have gone in these like wormholes like
because right now like
it's all about like
doing your own research
um so when you have a conversation with
someone and you're like hey this ukraine
thing's like like where'd you read where
did you read that
i don't know
like on the new what was the source yeah
and you're like uh i think like apple
news yeah i'm gonna do my own research
on that like how does that what does
that look like are you gonna go to
ukraine i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
fly there i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go i'm gonna watch cnn i'm
gonna watch fox and then i'm gonna right
right
you're only allowed to say you're doing
your own research if you have a jstor
account like if you are still subscribed
to like where you got your journal like
art when you were in college you had to
like store jstor jstor is
do you know
i was like
don't pretend you know jstor is like
this online database for just like
academic articles and it costs like six
hundred dollars a year
for college students
but also all news is gossip
on some level yeah until i promise you
like yeah and also be grateful for how
accurate the news is today as
like untrue is so much evidence news
used to be 200 years ago news used to be
hey there's a war where'd you hear that
some guy i saw it yeah yeah i just i had
a horse came up the path i think there's
going to be a war and you go ah it was
just people yeah playing telephone don't
ruin a good story with the truth that's
what everybody's motto is
actually
also like it is this i'm gonna watch cnn
i'm gonna watch fox and i'm gonna what
yeah yeah you're gonna pick which lie
you like yeah they're not even talking
about the same thing right right they're
talking about completely different
there's so much going on all the time
and then you go i said this to my guy i
was like then how do you know which one
is true i'll know
it'll feel true it'll feel true if it
feels true feelings that's the part
[Laughter]
try saying that in abc hr didn't go well
for me
but also i love that uh uh that for a
lot of people the more publicly
disgraced their thought leader is the
smarter they think they are they're like
dude you gotta check this guy out he was
fired from three universities yeah he
might yeah yeah he was banned from
youtube kicked off twitter yeah
kicked off the board not allowed to see
his kids seven shared you this guy must
know some shit yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know the powers that be are scared
of him yeah yeah yeah
the people that know shit are scared
they're quaking in their boots
why was he in kyrgyzstan in the first
place that's weird
who goes that's such a good that's
really dumb um also a big thing about
this new like
bro wellness stuff which a lot of
wellness grow wellness
it's um
it's shit that women knew as common
sense like 300 years ago
so when people like dude you know and
you gotta sleep eight hours a night
we're like
what
yeah we've known this for a while guys
and guess what moms don't get to do that
i was just about to say you guys needed
research to tell yourselves to keep
doing the thing that you've been doing
your wives give birth to a human child
it's all true
but then also they'll be like it's just
so loud to me they're like okay dude you
gotta drink like water every day right
yeah
i know that
get a glass deep breath
and
out like
yeah yeah it's called lamas
oh my god you've gone to the classes
with me the deep breath thing we've been
on that for a while every time we used
to get raped in the jungle we would just
know how to breathe through it like it's
just so much of this stuff is stuff it's
just so
also what are you
training for
oh yeah i love that you're staying in
shape i love that you're healthy it's
great it's just it's a little bit of a
whack-a-mole situation where it's like
like well i gotta do an ice bath uh six
times a day and you're like well but
you're also running 700 miles like if
you just ran like five mile i think it's
like the new form of addiction i think
it's a new form of addiction i think
people are getting sober from drugs
alcohol stuff like that and then they
get addicted like exercise and stuff
it's just a little bit like for people
that have um
been trying to take care of themselves
for a while like it's just a little bit
like why
are you getting paid four million
dollars a year to to like tell everyone
how to nap right right yeah
yeah i'm doing it and also listen to
your body
some people need less sleep some people
need more sleep it depends like i don't
know listen to your body is going to be
their next big breakthrough
100
yeah you heard it here first
so i guess i just i don't know it just
feels like uh i have to sit through a
lot of like being lectured about things
that are feel like they're kind of
comments that like just talk to your
like audience
yeah you don't exactly literally just
ask your aunts like the most wisdom is
actually in your mom's nursing home
at thanksgiving ask your aunt like what
should i do to have more energy
exactly what the fuck you do yep you
know like amphetamines
[Laughter]
all right what did you what are you guys
uh annoyed about um i have a lot of
coffee shop specific pet peeves
if you if you if you could guess that
from everything about me
um i spend a lot of time in coffee shops
because my like ac does not work in my
apartment
um and it just like gets baked baking
hot during the day so like when the ac
works here she has to put on parker it's
freezing it's there's a happy medium
there's a happy medium and we're not
we're not finding it um
but like coffee shops coffee shops that
only that have one single occupancy
bathroom okay for the entire coffee shop
right that feels like
an attack sadistic yeah
well in a city
where
homeless people
run amok
in a way
on meth
i mean here's the thing homeless people
on meth that's that i had to deal with
fighting a guy on that that was like
right had he been in a bathroom with me
i don't think i would have
tried it but it's the way i did but but
like usually they're locked they have a
code like that's not an issue it's just
like you're gonna have one bathroom
where everybody in the building is
drinking coffee
you're going to have one you're going to
have one bathroom with one toilet in it
for the entire building that's an insane
choice but
building what kind of but aren't coffee
shops small yeah but like they're
every i live on the east side of los
angeles everybody's hanging out coffee
shops all the time they're typically
tapping on their laptops like also when
they don't have wi-fi and they're like
talk to each other it's like i didn't
come here i did not i didn't come to
this coffee shop to experience the magic
of human connection yeah that's not why
i'm fucking
yeah and like the people that come to
this coffee shop with a sign like that
nobody wants to fucking talk to them no
oh my god that applies to you i don't go
to coffee shops to be alone or go on a
date with someone that might be a
murderer or work on your script to try
and see if you're
maybe to try and see if the guy that
you're dating is chokable that's why you
go to a coffee shop
emily what are you thinking about well
here's i do before i just like my job
before i talk about my pet peeves um
whitney cummings i
just want to say something
my pets yeah whitney's pets when i'm
feeling like super anxious like i need
to unwind i love to take a next evo cbd
gummy the best they are all natural
products backed by more scientific
studies than any other cbd brand and
they're developed by experienced
consumer healthcare and pharmaceutical
professionals this is the only thing
that comes from the earth that goes into
my body everything else is just that's
just that if you're going to do one
thing that's a good choice there's a
whole level on my period whole 30. these
are experiments
but also this is amazing because my
whole problem with the edible space etc
is that it just they all absorb at
different rates
yeah you know when it's going to hit you
and
if you're in some kind of pain or need
to fall asleep like you just have to
know that this absorbs within 10 minutes
that's so great so you're not getting a
stress migraine being like when is it
going to kick it has it kicked in i
don't know am i high i can't tell do i
always like see bears you know like
whatever it is so this is incredible and
um this is the only cbd product that i
am currently using there's so many out
there so many cbds i've tried like will
mess just not sit well with me and then
i start saying the actual alphabet cbd
abcd i prep jokes for this and that was
um
and also on top of that
[Laughter]
stop wondering if cbd is right for you
try next evo naturals stop wondering if
emily has a speech impediment okay they
have gummies mints and topical creams
clinically proven to be better absorbed
by your body get 25 off your first order
of 40 or more at nextevo.com with promo
code whitney that's 25 off at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o dot com promo code whitney
i have a lot of pet peeves today i want
to keep them tight though oh here we go
pet peeve people who as soon as they
show up to a party they tell you how
long they can stay
so when people come to a party and
they're like hey i can't stay long i
gotta i gotta go soon i decided you know
i've got another thing i gotta go to
yeah i got this other thing and you're
just like cool yeah right i'm chilling
yeah right right you're stressing me out
right no one i didn't ask for yourself
no one needs your schedule yeah say hi
just keep it to yourself we also don't
need to you i like i hate it when people
martyr themselves yeah like like they
they will purposely over book themselves
and then be like i'm
the busiest person in the world but like
socially like i'm not even talking about
work time management yeah yeah you're
back with time management and then the
narcissism of i used to be like this uh
i'm recovering for codependence help the
thing of like i have to go to this baby
shower yeah i have to go to this
birthday party like what if you don't go
they're gonna cancel oh
especially now that bachelorette parties
have to be
are on zoom no bachelorette parties are
all like a six day trip to the world's
most exotic location that was so sad
sorry but really quick the gangster ass
maid of honor who was like
bachelorette party this seems annoying
should we just do it on zoom like i love
that i love her too i
love that bitch yeah
yeah a zuma she was like yeah we're not
going anywhere he hates you
because there is a point i mean there is
a point where it's like you get the
invite for the engagement party and then
the bridal shot oh yeah wedding the
wedding and then the bachelorette party
you're like dude i am out of money yeah
oh it's just too expensive you want a
fucking present and then you want to
press oh yeah um they just the idea of
like i can't go and it's like why are
you involving me also let's say we have
five minutes to catch up yeah
that's a dream that's a dream is to go
like
i like this is what i do let's do five
minutes show up at the party and tell me
um how oh my god oh my god i i'm so i
like i can't be here long i just like
have four other things to do tonight
yeah oh cool well um
i got the invite and put in my calendar
so i'm gonna be here for okay well like
i got like four other invites and i like
also put them in the calendar i just so
i just like rounded it the person i
actually liked and i'm just here okay
well that's insane yeah okay cool
because like i have friends this is a
great i've had a great conversation with
you this has been every like it's so fun
to see you out i'm just so happy for you
that you get all these paperless posts
thank you it's almost there's so many
tabs open on my computer i just feel
like people like you more than they like
they must just like you more we should
have done this on zoom yeah
like i just feel like is that the key to
being a good friend you should show up
for 15 minutes and just bore everyone
right tears with all your other
obligations with the fact that you have
to take la siena got to your next thing
yeah like i got a kid
by the way where my computer is right
now oh my gosh
my computer has been stolen no i don't
want you to tell people that because
someone in l.a might find it and i don't
i don't want to tell them that good
fucking if you crack the password you
get all of them by the way i loved um uh
jeannie graffle once lost her joke
notebook and she was like i lost my joke
notebook
so i think someone stole it so if you
see anyone bombing in minneapolis
that's so good
um let's see my biggest pet peeve is
when guys put hot sauce in the condom
it really fucks up my plans is that when
you okay from when you finish this
because the way you're saying it makes
no sense so when you hold on when you
set something up just be i'm going to do
my auntie whitney shit here
when guys put a hot sauce in a condom
that's already been used right but that
was like a throwback to because everyone
knows it that's like that was like a big
story drake put hot sauce in a condom i
love emily's everybody knows like
i think
everybody knows this it was pretty
widely you're gaslighting me in a way
that is is i just got it everybody knows
that drake puts hot sauce in condoms pat
did you know that
i've heard of i didn't know it was drake
but i've heard of that move well every
guy's hurt
all right fine that was my joke i
prepared by the way who uses condoms i
haven't used a condom
since i was a kid since i started
choking men oh my god
i cut all that no don't i'm just saying
it's like it just set the stage for what
i'm hearing because but it was like but
it was just a casual it's a funny it was
the it was an aside it was going to be a
funniest side have that be a pet peeve
but that's like what a weird is crazy
that is crazy one's illegal and one's
just dicky
is it illegal to put hot sauce in your
used condom oh no but if you put hot
sauce in a condom before you used it
well yeah you just said hot sauce on a
condom that's like a sanic i'm sorry i
thought i thought you're putting it out
before you fuck me
like that's what a cannibal would do i'm
about to eat you so i want to just
drench you in that's hot once that's the
new iteration of hotspots
coming this fall
[Music]
i was gonna say like slow walkers but
that's just me
[Laughter]
so this is a
thing that i guess drake is rumored
allegedly without that yeah i have
umbrella insurance you guys don't yeah
but where are your guests i'm under the
umbrella can i get under can i get under
how big is the umbrella
[Laughter]
so it's that he puts hot sauce in a
condom after he's ejaculated
so that she can't take the sperm and
impregnate her right but what she he
doesn't know is you're just making the
cum more delicious
i like it that way it's just making me
go i really want this guy to be my kid's
dad wait yeah he's prepared he's a
coffee stuffy
he knows that a good she said i'm for
sure going to make sure i get pregnant
by you like you think that's the only
way we can fucking get like get out of
here also you think my pussy can't
handle a little hot sauce also by the
way it'll come right out because i put a
hole in it
oh my god
one of my pet peeves and this is a
really specific one but it's come up
recently in my life when people say that
scenes from an italian restaurant by
billy joel is their favorite song
what an obscure which one sorry scenes
from an italian restaurant by billy joel
cannot be your favorite song
pick a new song i've never even heard
i've never ever
okay is it from lady and the tramp no
it's like three different songs in one
it's like 10 minutes long he's like
telling this story of like different
things that happened at this italian
restaurant
this is something you've thought about
more than once yes
how old are the guys you're dating this
is these are nope this is nobody that i
are you dating a lot of guys from jersey
yes
oh get go stop but everybody knew
imagine that's the worst hold on if
billy eilish put out a 10 minute song
just going the bread and the
basket that might be my new favorite
song i loved it
but i'm saying if a woman like if if
if billy eilish was like the waiter is
here
yeah he's bringing the bread bring over
the balls
do you have gluten free crust
olives on the side
you would just go like oh this person is
their mind has lost their minds yeah
yeah
but once you're at his level you just
get to say yeah it is but like if a song
is over six minutes long people are
automatically like it's a masterpiece
if it changes tempo one time they're
like it's the best song i've ever
written it's like a person just not
severe ocd yeah like
pick a different it's funny that people
hate long movies
but love long songs oh my god the 10
minute vision of version of ultima the
five minute version is better
all too well i will that is not true i'm
correct craziest thing you've ever said
and you choke men in bed so
hold on okay i also could make one
argument i could make the argument
that
songs are too short
no they are there's a there's a happy
medium when a song you love you're like
why who decided one minute yeah 56
seconds yeah decided they should be this
short just just loop it yeah yeah yeah
like i had girls i had a like uh people
over to swim yesterday and if i like a
song i'll put it on a playlist twice
i'll repeat oh yeah
so and life is a highway it came on
twice in a row i'm walking to memphis i
was walking to memphis okay
and then cher did walk in memphis and it
went on back to back and i was like oh
no one's gonna notice everyone's like is
this the same song
like i got so roasted for it and i was
just like well this song should be six
minutes yeah yeah it's such a jam yeah
that's fair uh guns and roses did some
good long songs uh isn't it free bird
long yes i'm not saying that there can't
be good long songs that aren't good
songs not talking
it shouldn't be talking and also like if
the song changes tempo and vibe like
four times during the course of the song
that's four songs you don't get to pick
a song that's four songs in one oh i
have a good pet peeve okay please
is it people with obscure pet peeves
[Music]
[Laughter]
say it
say it
i didn't
i love that the new shut up is say it
don't shut up
i love it george first do you remember
how shut up was the biggest bird we were
not allowed to say it we weren't like
when we were kids yes
if i said shut up one of my siblings if
someone i sired told me to shut up oh
yeah never to my parents
i wouldn't dream of doing that can i
tell you the big slap in the face that i
got literal changed my life i've told
you oh i love this story yeah i call my
mama hooker
and i should have said sex worker
she was like you're problematic
um also sex worker i i
all sexes work
that's that is
but only some people get paid for it i
don't like this thing where now i'm
because you're a sex worker i'm a sex
volunteer yes i'm bad with money because
you because i'm not charging you you
some
someone with a stranger's dick in her
mouth got a venmo account now i'm bad at
business
okay this is a big okay so the carriage
horses thing happened in new york where
a horse carriage was um the horse
collapsed it up this happens all the
time it happens every day you guys now
know why i am so cray-cray
so
when i say things about this on
instagram when there isn't of that
morning like a horrible horse
in humane accident no one cares they
think i'm crazy they think i'm a
childish uh childish i was gonna say
childless but whatever um
why do you care about horses yeah
there's other things that care about
other things that matter like politics
jesus christ guys um and uh and then
this happens and i get a billion texts a
billion calls what can we do what can we
do what you could have done is something
a year ago
to make sure this didn't happen it
happens all the time and then it's just
really you trying to participate and
like check a box in your conscious and
you're just wasting the people's time
that actually do the work year round
yeah so so the fact that everyone is
dming and calling me it's like well guys
i'm actually like
like talking to the people that own the
horses and i'm like in the trenches and
you're calling me and what you're doing
is actually what you can do is get out
of the way for the people that actually
have committed to this as their life you
know what i'm saying like this is
it's so frustrating and then also like
this thing where people don't want to do
their own research i can't believe i'm
i'm back
to do your own research sorry because
when you i think a lot of people really
want to help these days with many things
but when you go to someone that is like
a
whatever i don't
spearheading a spearheading in some way
or or is 24 7 365 on an issue um
chances are they've already told you
what to do and you didn't do it yeah
what i'm saying you know where to find
what to do but you just kind of want to
get credit for being a good person or
maybe i get that it's horrifying to see
but i don't want to post that shit on my
feed all year long because it's a bummer
it's depressing i think sometimes well
as soon as you start doing it people are
like stop it yeah oh my god yeah or
you're crazy they just think you're
crazy i think that and a lot of animal
rescue people are bat shit crazy people
that have like very traumatic childhoods
and they see innocent
voiceless animals and they see they were
molested and they were once an innocent
voiceless person that couldn't get out
of the circumstances so there's a lot of
that but um
what you can do is go to the person's uh
like um brittany cunningham talks about
this too about in the you know racism
field of like people are like what do i
do it's like buy my book yeah buy the
book i love it right you've got the maya
sat it's like buy the book like you're
trying to get something for free from me
that i already put work into writing and
making right not written a book about
you know the animal rescue stuff but
there's no way you don't know at all
what to do right um and so uh that has
been something that's been really
frustrating to me because i actually
can't
save the horses if you won't stop
texting me right i mean right
because i'm just or just repost the
people that know what they're doing yeah
just re just find the people and repost
it oh god yeah when people refuse to
just like actually
do one search on either google or
instagram or whatever it is to talk who
cares like
and they just ask a question
right because you care two days a year
or only after the fact right so had
people listened you know four or five
years ago this never would happen in the
first place and it would be shut down
you know but so it's like this 80d with
your outrage of like everyone you just
want to jump on a different cause every
day just like pick three things you care
about yeah and dedicate all your life
right because that is when things
actually get done when everyone wants to
be involved in every cause nothing gets
done
performance it's like find the thing
that you care about so much that you
every day for free are like involved
in something you know so the other thing
is like uh jesus christ is that i have a
um
people always text me and call me and dm
me and everything about like dog stuff i
don't know how i i i think i put myself
in this position um uh but
if your dog if you have a problem with
your dog eating a problem most people
don't most of your dogs are
clinically obese and it's driving me
fucking insane because it's like how do
you not know
google your dog's breathing yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what it should look
like yeah
yeah your dog you know that's not what a
dog it looks like mr potato head you
know you're yeah a chihuahua shouldn't
be 18 pounds right right it should be
four pounds right yeah i'm saying so
that definitely drives me nuts but the
other thing is like you know what do i
do about this dog you make it so it's
not gonna die three years prematurely
right by over feeding it because you're
just like projecting your shit onto it
or you want it to like you yeah
your dog will like you if you stop
killing it by over feeding it right and
um
joke joke um and the other thing is this
is driving me insane because it's such a
small thing
but it makes me so i think as someone
with the misophonia sound stuff other
people's noise really stresses me out
with the ocd i get super distracted and
but um dogs
with any kind of collar that is metal
against metal your dog is fucked you
know like i can't train my dog my dog is
easily distracted they won't eat yeah
because the metal dog tags are hitting
against the metal bowl so it's too loud
for them
you know how do you not know that how
can just people not doing the least
amount of abs i almost think if someone
that just said everyone should start
googling shit more and stop asking me or
other people like
maybe do the tiniest bit of research
before you get a dog you know like buy a
book everyone knows that dogs have hyper
yeah incredible hearing right why would
you put three dog tags that
jangle
yeah two inches from their ears i don't
know i mean that i have that's why like
i never would have thought about that i
i think that people have best intentions
and their hearts in the right place but
you have to like do
inventory and research before you get
have a child you read a baby box right
right you know you're responsible for
something else like just learn about it
or when someone tells you just listen
yeah yeah and then tell other people why
don't do your own research yeah yeah
but it's like i just tell someone else
yeah do you know what i'm saying so it's
like and then you take it on i can't do
it all like i'm in this situation where
i just feel like i'm super overwhelmed
and like super frustrated and like
because
people just throw problems at me to
solve all day yeah like you can solve
this yeah like it's a click away you're
probably a problem solver yeah like tell
me about my dog i did an episode with dr
quan yeah and we talked all about it go
to the dog training episode send this to
your friends like share it like you guys
have to take responsibility at some
point for your own wealth of knowledge
you know yeah it's just that people like
cliff notes you know what i mean yeah
but how many times do i have to say it
or you know what i'm saying like i don't
i don't know i just think that like
before i ask someone a question i first
i'm like how can i solve this problem
myself who else can i look to who else
can i mean tim ferriss had a great
episode on dog training with a dog
trainer or puppy training um house
training and i send that to people all
the time yeah you don't know what i'm
saying yeah like why aren't you
you're responsible for your friend group
so they say about the course carriages
what do we do shame your family right
shame your friends to go yeah go write
comments on everyone that is go stan you
know what to do oh yeah stand at the
line people also use it as a way to
connect with you do you know what i mean
because they know they know that you're
passionate about it and they're kind of
they're like hey i want what you know i
care about that like they're they're not
doing like you don't care about it you
only care about it the day they care
about you yeah and they i mean that you
know they're expressing time
i think they're not seeing it it's
misguided yeah yeah that's why i'm
saying no that's what i'm saying yeah
yeah that's very this is the
co-dependence of like nice isn't always
nice yeah like totally somebody busy who
like dedicates their life to something
when the day that they're probably gonna
be the busiest right because they're
dealing with like right you know yeah um
to just go i'm gonna just ask her a
bunch of questions that she's already
answered on her instagram that this is
the other thing when someone's like you
know so uh what should we do about the
horse carriage thing so you don't follow
me right or you muted me
people like the same thing we were just
talking about not everyone watches every
single episode or every piece of content
totally but when it comes to animal
stuff i don't think i'm shy about
posting about it yeah you know at least
not in the inside that's the question of
like you like best intention versus
impact yeah but also your intentions
figure out you have to do it you have to
do something asking someone else what to
do i know that even if i tell you what
to do you're not going to do it i
already know you're not the person
that's going to do it because you're
already looking for someone else to do
it to do it for you yeah and you're just
trying to get credit i don't i i half
believe what you're saying mm-hmm like
there are so
you know um you guys know her from the
flight attendant brilliant actress like
you know she was like the only person i
can engage with because she's like great
let's i'll be there let's organize the
protest let's make it happen like i know
she's the real deal though but like it's
it really damaged it's damaging a lot of
my friendships because i'm like how can
you think
that like texting me about this or
sending it how do you think i first of
all i haven't seen this everyone was
sending it to me i'm like bitches
right i already tried to rescue that
exact horse right i told you this was
gonna happen too right so this horse has
been sick for years you know like so
you know but then i also i have to look
at myself and go okay
maybe a lot of this is like
maybe a lot of it i think i've made
public and haven't because a lot of the
animal rescue stuff you have to do
anonymously and a lot of the deals that
i make with people to get animals out is
i'll if i won't post about this if you
give me the horse yeah you know i won't
post about this if you give me the dog
or whatever the tiger the lion or
whatever but i think it's also important
that people know that people that abuse
animals are
sociopathic criminals yes
so there's no
larger craziness so so these are not p
you have to do it
people have to stop
using the product or buying the service
the the the only way that anything that
abuses animals goes away is that people
stop paying for it right like it's the
blackfish effect like blackfish came out
on netflix back when netflix had two
things come out a year and so everybody
watched it and everybody was like sea
world is one of the most fucked up
places in the world yeah and so
everybody stopped going there they i
mean obviously you know that you know
when you started that a child
a kid in class got upset and yes and
then freaked out and i think her parents
made the document like she was like they
were going to do a field trip to
seaworld and she was like we can't do
that like a child knew what to do yeah
but like but like exactly i mean they're
like
when there's enough like righteous
indignation about something like then
people are able to sort of like jump on
this bandwagon and there's all these
resources and people sharing things and
whatever but yeah i see what you're
saying like the the person stop sharing
stuff yeah go to michael's get a poster
board and a bunch of pens and whatever
print out the horse that is on the
ground dying hold it go stay go organize
the thread with your friends
everyone takes an hour and you're
standing there as people get in line to
get on the carriage rides to make it
less magical yeah you gotta make it less
magical because a lot of people that
patronize that business are not american
they're they're they're tourists they do
know better on some level i i don't
think anyone doesn't know i think i
don't think they know how bad it
is i don't think they know the exactly i
do think that people that like have have
gone and ridden elephants didn't know i
think they thought they were sanctuary
if you're
that is i don't think there's any excuse
anymore no not anymore i don't think but
i think at some point and they're
they're not an excuse but there was an
under like okay i understand why you did
it by the way i read an elephant when i
was road red i wrote an elephant when i
was in my 20s it's part of the reason i
at the end of every episode i say don't
write elephants because it's like i know
i have like i
think about it every day i hate myself i
had no idea until i got there i was in a
relationship that was very like whatever
you want whatever you want he's like
let's go ride elephants and i'm like oh
my god yes it's at a sanctuary and that
like yeah you think yeah i mean any
animal that is uh
apex predator if you're touching them if
you're on them is something wrong such
an extreme amount of abuse it's
unthinkable right and i and i try to not
share it all because i know it's too
upsetting and overwhelming and i don't
wish the things that i have nightmares
about on anyone yeah if you can ever
touch an animal like that it's not the
right place if if you can touch that
animal they are
like on the verge of death and drugged
within a rush of their life and whatever
yeah you know so and we're raised um
from being a baby and people go oh yeah
they raised since a bottle it's like
they they don't want the mom raises
that's so dark so if the mom is not
there i think but think but this is
where it's just critical thinking i
remember when i was in school and we
were talking about critical thinking i
was like what is this it's just like
we all know
that the most vicious animals
uh or the animals are their most vicious
when they are protecting their young
what animal would voluntarily surrender
their baby to a circus freak
who's gonna make it um
but yeah balance on a ball right like
imagine you know what i'm saying yeah
this is a blind spot that
you have to look at what else is going
on in your life like you can you can't
move through the world this clueless
like you just can't like it's just not
healthy because you know it's just like
a matter of going like how do i move
through the world a little more
mindfully with a little more empathy and
like turn your fucking brain on like if
you're walking through the world just so
self-obsessed and in your own phone and
in your own thing and you think that
everything in the world just exists to
serve you or be in your photos
like yeah i'm just saying like when this
happened it just made me go like
everyone needs to just like i don't
understand why we have the most access
to information ever yet people don't
seem to be wanting to use it um okay so
let us know what you guys think give us
your feedback send us birthday messages
for whitney uh the email uh good for you
fans at gmail.com and also if you want
to send questions if you want to send
suggestions pitches feedback all of it i
think we should start reading like three
or four questions an episode maybe to
end yeah kind of thing yup yup
um and we love you guys and um grace
watson what is your instagram is your
are you private wait no i'm public okay
stan dot hathaway
she's not budging on this slash
instagram.com
which as auntie whitney big hollywood
baby advice
what is it normally i know your advice
before you give it how is someone how do
you get famous if no one knows my name
my name is lots of people have been able
to find me
my instagram how many
likes six thousand four thousand i don't
know okay my instagram handle used to be
nooner joy and we should change it back
to that because i didn't know nooner
meant afternoon quickie sex i thought
her uncle wrote the song afternoon
delight that's so funny and she didn't
know that so funny well my uncle
wrote the song okay my parents told me
that song was about a menu at a dc
restaurant called clyde's it was called
afternoon delight i was told it was
about appetizers i get why you want to
talk back so much you would lie to us
a lot
you have you you need to investigate
things as they come up for sure i like
to just take things as they come
i just roll with it
[Laughter]
whatever you want to tell me
no you're not
you are
i was waiting to see how long later yeah
we should call you footnote like
it's like you should call me butt
yeah it's just like yeah
bj novak used to have an amazing joke
hugo the whole premise of improv is yes
and yeah like i like to improvise with a
no
but
yeah
he also had a joke he would go battered
women
sounds delicious
[Laughter]
and then
my favorite one is he would go he
doesn't really he actually called me
like
a couple months ago i was like can we
can i come out and do stand up with you
so he might be doing stand up again but
i think he had a movie come out and yeah
he's busy a bunch of stuff but he goes
um uh he goes my girlfriend uh sorry oh
my god i just dropped my girlfriend off
at the airport
and i am going to pick her up when she
calms down
[Laughter]
if you guys like one-liners also dan
mintz is amazing
he's on what is he writing on now he
writes on a ton of shows brilliant
stand-up one-liners he goes um oh god he
talks really like droll you know really
like monochromatic not monotone he goes
um
uh you know be really confusing if
someone was performing abortion
and someone ran in and yelled abort
i'm bored
[Laughter]
on that note
don't ride elephants
we love you
put that in the next round of
impressions
do that one wait i don't know i want to
see i need i'm dying to see more of this
character please impression of an
elephant ride me with your knees
ride me if you don't know it's bad i
don't care
fine you didn't know
i forgive you
for giving people a break by the way
emily
will emily is to children what i am to
animals so when i uh
get a target uh that has my child i will
be like what i didn't know that they
couldn't stick their fingers in electric
socks it's like where do you find this
information i'll say listen to my
podcast
go to my instagram emily's podcast it's
called afternoon delight it comes out
thursday afternoons
and it's a delight
love you all all right do really quickly
audio only pre-roll oh gosh
oh sorry really quick hold on oh one
more pet peeve are we rolling oh i know
it was about to be said pet peeve i
didn't i know what you're going to say i
know what you're going to say okay why
is it frustrating because i never notice
it it didn't it literally
with the lights i cannot tell
that's the thing you guys you notice
things on your face that nobody else
noticed correct i don't as a universal
have you actually read the comments
i always read the comments but i don't
there's some people that
truly think i'm an abusive relationship
i
have eyeliner
all i look like a trap i don't agree
with you though i don't agree with you i
can't i can't i know you like pandas but
i can't look like this correct something
that i can't see
is wrong yeah pat do you see the stuff
under my eyes the black well i feel like
you just touched it and it made it worse
it didn't look like that two seconds ago
saboteurs
i mean i'm dressed like a freaking
german milk bait today
i'm really stealing my
angle
i know your angles and i did have that
shirt stripes and bows
get your own brand oh yeah emily i'm
wearing a shirt that you wore this in
college was my favorite shirt yes i am
really into buying new marc jacobs stuff
that's 20 years old um but yes it is a
pet peeve of mine when my makeup is
running down my face and i look like
marilyn manson not the time to look like
marilyn manson and no one says anything
didn't notice it otherwise i would have
love you bye-bye
[Music]
four four four five
[Applause]